it's Jim Norton and Sam Roberts and our
friend Tom Papa has stopped in hi guys
and you have a special coming on Epic's
which we mentioned this morning when is
it Friday Friday it airs Friday on
Epic's it's called human mule meaning
what
shove things up your ass no that's what
I kind of do I was like are we we going
through uncharted tarring carrying your
whole life on your on your back it
relates to a joke okay Oh on your back
you know it's probably best described
there's like a like a visual of it um
there's a time billboard up in Times
Square it's not a big deal but you I may
be after your show like you can walk by
it and you see it oh yeah yeah I never
got one from epics they I guess never
had faith in the kid probably wasn't
nearly as big a deal when you were on
Epic says it has been Tom Pappas that
would be the implication actually just a
lot of a lot of begging a lot of
emailing the whole time what about a
billboard guys have a guy's time screwed
location ality the only better one is
the one right by my house is what they
put when literally like on my way to
like driving my kids to school yeah
they're really nice they did actually do
that for me I stand corrected I remember
that yeah yes I'm wrong it's great do
you point it out to your kids like hey
just so you know they're like is
somebody we don't have to drive this way
short or the other way anymore no it is
the billboards actually the best part
nobody doesn't like to see themselves on
a billboard
it never isn't an amazing feeling it's
really pretty great [ __ ] it's really
great I actually got to a point now
where it's been up for like a month and
now I'm coming like driving up late to
school like I hope is still up
electronic now just old school the
electronic one sometimes I flip through
and then I try to drive slow and people
are in the car
it's gonna flip in a chain and it
doesn't if the Times Square won a
traditional billboard - I think so
that's pretty incredible because I know
there are billboards a lot most of the
billboards now in Times Square go like
there's like five or six different
things on each bill yes probably what is
this yeah I don't know he said that he
thinks it might be a tradition that's
his way of going into the epics probably
realized that you know we have Tom Papa
doing a special with us we better do a
permanent billboard cool thing they're
doing also is uh because epics not a lot
of people some people don't have epics
like if it's on DirecTV they don't have
epics sure but they're making you can go
to epics calm and watch all this stuff
for free for the whole month
why does go to epics calm and they'll
tell you to either get a free membership
or whatever for the for the whole month
so you'll be able to see it and maybe
even see your specials yeah I like those
guys a lot man they're really when
dealing with like networks that they're
like the really really honest good guy I
like them very much
yeah and that you can just get it for
free for the whole month is so it
definitely helps the special a lot it'll
drop on iTunes next week also
so the Tom Appa special they're giving
away for free no IIIi don't know if I
put it that way I feel like what they
did was they realized what a monster of
a vehicle they had with Tom papa and
they realized that they wanted to Center
the entire network uh-huh on the release
I feel like that's how you say is that
more reveal that seems I don't know why
but not that far right okay not not like
hey we're doing a free one so let's just
put this year that's what the Billboard
was just watch it it's free funny idea
yeah where did you I where'd you shoot
I shot it in Cleveland oh yeah we
talking about it yeah it's right after
I've shot in Cleveland lunch to it I
[ __ ] love Cleveland I like the people
in Cleveland you know they got that good
kind of bitter you know I grew up you as
you did in New Jersey so when you come
from a place that's a punch line
naturally right you kind of like you
understand those people unless you're
Cleveland is I never
understood when I was in school many
many years ago it was a kid and was we
had some speaker doing something and a
joke he made and I didn't get at the
time we said something about New Jersey
which is like this great land of ours is
the armpit and I didn't understand the
smell was funny but didn't know why so
then do you kind of when you're in LA
yeah you kind of walk around like with a
little bit walk anywhere in LA my right
a long time ago the traffic on the 405
welcome but are you like is it a little
bit condescending like your vibe about
LA because you're like I'm used to I'm
used to Jersey I'm used to Cleveland
people like LA is not that no it's far
from that happy there right and you're
like there's nothing you guys don't even
realize that there's nothing there's the
Everly I mean honestly that's why I
that's part of why I shot in in
Cleveland that's why I do like my my
live radio show all the time I was doing
it in LA and New York now it's pretty
much exclusively in new you know you
need because in LA people are happy
they're at the beach they're content
with their lives and they think
something they still in their minds are
like something's gonna happen
yeah something hasn't happened they're
like no I'm here though and it's gonna
happen for me
yeah they don't to get people out to
shows and stuff you go to a place like
leveland where what else is happening
it's right knowing that it's nickname is
the mistake on the lake big fish in a
small pond I understand that show maybe
that's what it is
yeah la it's hard there's so many things
that Kapiti in Vegas you're competing
with big acts you competing with Vegas
really I said when you're in Vegas
you're there's so many things to do oh
right LA saying there's a lot of stuff
to do this other than that I know I was
right at least I understand no that's
not what I was saying yeah no I was
saying I went to your show in LA and it
was like sold out no it was all day in
problems right
the theater was not as good it was no no
which theater I don't remember I blocked
it out that's always the word you stick
to the clubs when you go to LA then I do
okay that's all it is
I mean it's really tough to fill up a
theater in
in LA for something less yeah for some
people it's effortless it Mart isn't
having it isn't having much of a problem
yeah but I mean really established big
guys like yourself it's a tough ticket
to move and also people get stuff for
free out there all the time you go you
know they go to these shows and you have
a Judd Apatow bringing up Adam Sandler
and Spade and it's like you see me
whatever the sheriff but now so
Cleveland was good and I did it in like
July which is always a nice time yeah
that's not a bad time to be right before
the repeal it get cold
good good observation we was a tough
gang up here this morning nursers the
whole lot the whole room was crowded
during the commercial break because I
guess they did a fire drill oh I saw a
sign that said fired but the elevators
weren't turned off or any now no no
worry because I think right before you
got here some of the talent Booker's
were panicking oh really I guess they
turned off the elevators because you I
don't know I guess in case of a fire you
wouldn't use them yeah and then where
the fire goes you know in a fire they go
in that there's a vacuum that goes into
the elevators and it shoots fireballs oh
no you don't get to be in there at all
to keep the door shut all the fireballs
are contained fireballs are contained ok
guess you know what you're getting
trapped in between floors because what
happens if your elevators going down
there's some kind of a problem you're
gonna get trapped in between floors and
the fireballs start to hit I don't know
if there's fireballs and I just know
you're getting it trapped in between
floors are you talking like that for
this is next week we're gonna premiere
Craig Schenkel discusses rap y-you know
what the worst part about doing this
show with Jim is what I keep getting
teases like last week I just got a
random text from Jim that said hey
remind me uncle Paul remixes and I went
I don't know what uncle Paul remixes are
but I certainly don't want to remind you
of them we should do some uncle Paul's
whole ship made it into our
the Lenny Marcus's wedding which tip
there I don't think you told me that she
I forgot what it shipped you at the
wedding
Tom Tom official I officiated the West
right that's right I I was the the
minister mm-hmm and Lenny's wife is a
huge chip fam right why she married chip
so Portland is gonna be tortured forever
wife and joined this idiotic character
she really does love chip yeah yeah when
I talked to her like before I want to
get some information on what was going
on and she brought chip up several times
yeah she's she gets it
she understand so I threw chip into the
vows and it got a and I still cheer from
the audience did it yeah do you want is
when you system a chip and she likes
chip chip person and people laughed and
it's one of those moments that you
almost do and I'm not kidding when I was
like I wanted to go [ __ ] yeah
she might have laughed but I was like
it's inappropriate at the ceremony
because the family in this children it
was really hard to not do I know but I
didn't want to be the [ __ ] if it
didn't get a laugh to go uh and I don't
want to it's better to not do it than
take a chance at a guy's wedding it's
just it was it wasn't just her way it's
Lenny's wedding and there is a lot of
like you know old people in suits I've
told this story before but I've never
seen a more satisfied look on Norton's
face then at my wedding because the
entire lead-up to the wedding Edgar kept
texting and saying that he was gonna
object and the Jes as a woman of lower
stock and that she's not an appropriate
bride and like everything that a girl
would say and of course I was like I
would let just know that all this was
going on so we're literally my dad
married us but my dad goes if anybody
has any objections now is the time to
say something whatever he said and Jim
didn't say anything but he knew that on
that day with me and Jes and my dad up
there and all family and friends and not
even
nobody from the show Jim knew that he
was in my head because I looked out into
the audience and just made direct eye
contact with Jim who was just sitting
there amongst everybody else with this
giant smile I was happy for my friends
and Lenny's not by the way he's not
doing a podcast with Kevin anymore
came out they dug up Kevin did red eye
with me last night Oh Brennan yeah funny
dude it was really yeah so what happened
with him is that I mean I know I told
Kevin on town like you know I know you
guys have this on-air thing but if he's
your on-air partner like for real like
you got a they gotta be a certain
camaraderie you share because you are in
a thing together well the you know the
hook of the show is that uh is that
Kevin is crazy and angry and it turns
out that's not an act right he's
actually crazy
yeah he's quite angry yeah he's very
angry and he really is crazy and was
apparently texting Lenny all the time
and yelling and screaming at him and all
this stuff and yeah and let me not
believe cuz he couldn't take it he
couldn't take it and then I think the
the final straw apparently was they
wanted to do it on Mondays but Monday
was a Jewish holiday and they said we
have to do it on Tuesday his lady's
Jewish and Kevin said no we're doing it
on Monday anyway and he used somebody
else and so I think a little
anti-semitic shadings was brought in and
that was it yeah that's crazy it was
working it's like I don't understand
when things were working why you do you
know what I mean and that was it was a
newer show but it their chemistry Lenny
was good in that role like I'm not
saying he was wrong to leave if it was
really miserable but I guess but some
people thought like you were working
with OB who that I mean I don't know I
don't know I don't know you know Kevin
told me last night he didn't know he
didn't know that he would come in and do
the show it he didn't know you and Opie
disliked each other
it wasn't even it was more like I felt
even from the beginning it was just one
of those things where there's a couple
of good show it was some very funny
moments but it was it just to me didn't
work for
beginning because it was something that
had been gutted yeah it was a show that
Anthony had been removed from forcefully
right never fun right because of that
because those dynamics there was some
good shows from great mall yeah of
course right but because of the dynamics
the way it was set up it was it was
never gonna work I thought I thought no
I'm not blaming him I'm you know I was
[ __ ] to the percent of it all right no
did you 20% as far as the
decision-making ability did you feel at
the time like there was less response
from the fans and stuff like less
activity on Twitter or what did you feel
no no I felt it was more response from
the fans but they were not fan responses
positive response yes oh yeah and a lot
of the times I felt they were unfair and
wrong and other times I thought they
were right right you know they're not
stupid yeah yeah some of them are crazy
and they get what bugs me about fans
when they get into your motors and they
think they know wired and sick now
you're wrong like you you're making me
having shitty motives but there's a lot
of things they think this is funny and
that's not funny and they look yeah
they're right about a lot of it I'm
right I thought Kevin was gonna snap on
red eye last night cuz we were with this
guy like in between it was it was Kevin
and this guy in me and one of the girls
that was on the show but the guy kept
interrupting Oh everyone like he was
interrupting me Kevin finally just goes
to throw up a little bit ta did because
the buttons don't push right yeah sound
effects really shouldn't take three
pushes why do you think Kevin was in a
snap because the guy kept interrupting
him there you go I just pushed it look
don't interrupt me cut to supress we've
already been over that I know that but
I'm doing it a little daintily press I
did pay off what the [ __ ] am i pressing
hey princess [ __ ] be honest I'll pay
for a bit break you through a whole iPad
on the one of those things that's a
reactionary thing if they take your iPad
now he's starting on it's a show iPad
yeah you get out of here are you putting
it in your ass it's an iPad Adrian be
honest yeah I fist aggravating is
because it's a reactionary
like when you do stuff like that it's
like it look what I want to say buttons
you push and when it just constantly
can't work it's [ __ ] a grits that's
really lame be honest Jim wasn't pushing
the buttons right was he did you film
that I put I press and I put I slash
button when there's a reaction when
you're reacting to something you're not
supposed to go yeah it's not the way it
works with timing what did Mars tell us
it was Adrian a push or a press Mars
also told me who made this higher so I
could stand but he made it longer I
still have to bend forward but by the
back I can do how about an old fashioned
machine with some real buttons on I
wanted that bland I wanted classics
2016 bro yeah we're snapchat news you
don't need buttons going the comedy
language please Hey Adrian's getting it
by pressing give it not and to spur the
moment on the table he's not he was back
there for there were five minutes hey so
what happened I mean I was by my right
hand did it easier come a righty Adrian
hang on keep that by age Adrian keeps up
by you for a second because I wanted to
tell Adrienne that on red eye there was
a guy that kept interrupting us don't
interrupt me [ __ ]
that's quite time it sure is if you're
holding it ready to press that button
right right
it sure is okay you also have to have
put in your body like maybe Jimmy's a
little like a real Turkey so we wrong
button [ __ ] how about this one how
about this one sure there was a are you
gonna do this one Jimmy I'll do it okay
let's see if Jim can get this so so
we're on red eye and I'm sitting there
talking with Kevin and this guy named
Amy starts talking
[Music]
people thought I did say that was worth
saving but I was asking for I'll go do
it again
okay we were sitting there and it was
Kevin and I on redeye we were talking
about no apology and this this man named
Sarah that was on the show with us oh
yeah I'm gonna come in that context no
it was uh we're talking right how about
like Trump in the plane and everything
and this guy whose name was Kristin
starts talking all right three times
that was off and it was the wrong button
so awful it was wrong so even hitting
the wrong thing that main stinks you
shouldn't be it stinks he needs a median
it's it's almost like and I should be
doing it right-handed because I better
deck stare at my right hand but it's
almost like it should just be quick you
know what I mean when you walk through
automatic when you walk through like
automatic doors and stuff does it take a
couple times to open we know a king a
soul you know who helped us hook it up
the male engineer whose name is Jessica
oh okay I see Jessica I need the buttons
I want the old machine back hate this
thing stinks [ __ ] hate it
Jim why not every city on an iPad
because again if you can plan any other
second but so much of it is just well
why don't we start doing that instead
cuz if we may not have access to it 360
so if you want I can start faxing you my
jokes the night before Oh No how do you
not have a fax no where's Kenny Kenny
I was gonna ask Kenny ho and it was
Kenny's the comedian around here all
right something's really good why would
you have that club soda does the name
Kenny uh no I didn't realize that we
weren't gonna be allowed to share Kenny
oh I am I asked to have him be a part of
this but I guess we're not permitted to
it makes sense
so how was Kevin on red I was he is his
fun antics oh you thought he was a snap
on that guy yeah did the guy hit he did
he yell at the guy he goes like he did
at this moment where like the guy was
the guy to interrupted me and rub the
girl he's a guy I didn't know he was
some he used to be a Democratic
strategist now he's a radio show host
but James Carville he's got improv
training too so yeah and he kept
interrupting
well [ __ ] why is this guy forgetting
interrupting me let me let me talk let
me talk where's Neil [ __ ] Neil and
we're [ __ ] Lenny I'm gonna do the
show what the [ __ ] did he goes like
language young man good job in the
middle of trying to land one of his
punchlines and I starts talking and he
just like turns over to him and just
yells at him could I finish yeah so
there's no is he still doing in the show
with somebody else doing his part no
Lenny I don't think is doing a no
letting us out and okay yeah I think
Kevin is doing his job
it's just misery with no company that's
it yeah misery loves company except
everybody leaves you maybe it doesn't
make misery is just misery just old
miserable Kevin yeah that was him misery
loves the stench of its own smell you
can see my new special on facts always
the jokes compass trying to expand their
audience but old-fashioned machinery
human Mull that the guy yeah that's him
Christopher hon I don't barely know
it's been Bailey I don't know
Christopher says he progressive
political commentator and syndicated
radio host runner and improv comic
sweets do not equal agreement okay
runner and improv comic I don't know him
I don't think I mean he wasn't terrible
he just kept interrupting yeah but he
wasn't doing it to be a dick he was just
it's just him just jumping it's just a
loud guy were you well-received on the
show okay I mean I think so I usually
get invited back you know they're hoping
to lure me over by bringing sand I saw
the show before I was doing this show oh
I was doing I started doing the show a
year ago it's a fun show to do yeah they
invited me back so I would I got my next
red-eye date so I'd assume I did all
right
oh it's the host Tom Shalom Shalom Tom
she loses the house yeah I thought is
that other guy Greg I felt was brilliant
to but you're doing the five he's got a
bunch of other stuff a good job - yeah
like town I love Tom Shalini
I love Andy levy it's Andy I think is
how you pronounce his not be fun to
handle of a yeah no I think it's just a
Taliban I think it's pronounced Andy
levy I think Oh Andy lavage
so why isn't a Kevin getting a co-host
cuz no one wants to work with him
apparently he's not kidding when he says
bad things about you know what the [ __ ]
Lenny he's married now I know that he's
trying to get his wife to stop listening
to chip on a loop oh come on
nice Jew Hira
Donald Trump is Time Magazine's Man of
the Year is he yes yeah I mean sure that
makes sense yep at first it was like I
guess some people were like what the
[ __ ] what [ __ ] what the [ __ ] yeah I got
a podcast what am I gonna be man here
but then I we like I think I was ama bin
Laden was man in the year one year and
he was Man of the Year one year so it's
just if you have a lot of impact right
and he definitely had the most impact
here how sure the head
did you see by the I mean Jim I know
you're a fan of his tweets did you see
the airplane tweet I guess about the
bullying and by the four billion he's
right
but then he wrote canceled order under
it as if he was instructing following
via Twitter to cancel the order
because Boeing they think it might've
been a response to Boeing criticizing
him but
I don't care probably was but billion
dollars [ __ ] that for presidential
planes were you out of your mind for one
plane jack no why for me I'm not spy for
more I thought was for the fleet pride
for the fleet right it tries to say yeah
but how many are on the fleet I don't
know but it's definitely not for
wonderful no no but I'm saying you got
the Air Force wander your Air Force to a
couple robberies are these their Air
Force force for do they make the cop
money how many how long how long do they
make the copters as well yeah I'm sure
they do become any part of the fleet
how many flying apparatuses are there
but they got a couple drones to those
counters fly em show two identical
planes 747-200 models specifically
modified by the Air Force so I was like
a ton of money is like three hundred
million dollars for security for
communication like just to hook up the
plane way you can communicate securely
was three hundred million dollars and
they also said they don't know where he
got that four billion number from he
might have made it up yeah they can't
sounds hard to believe I don't think he
would have done that but yeah so he went
on Twitter and he wrote canceled order
so I guess Boeing cuz Boeing when they
were doing the new Air Force One my
theory is that this was not his plane
Boeing is signing this contract for
planes the future presidents would use
and the same reason why Donald Trump the
whole time he was campaigning was like
you know the laws that I took advantage
of Robin and make it so nobody else can
because you know that's the problem it's
the same reason why he's trying to get
rid of this plane it's like he gets all
the fun but no fun for anybody else he
doesn't want to know they're gonna stop
there's a better plane coming for the
next president he's like no no no we're
not paying for that but I believe the
orders even canceled so that that won't
happen let them let them [ __ ] do
something on fly TWA he went on the
Twitter though and just wrote canceled
order it was like his SNL tweets about
how it said just it's terrible and the
imprint not funny not funny he goes like
the impression is so bad and then if you
watched his speech last night he's doing
all the little Trump things that Alec
Baldwin always does like it's a great is
that correct
he's really good he really is the best